FAQ avec les chattes
Moi dans la vie j'aime bien les CHATS ..... et j'aime bien aussi les FAQ
Alors voici un FAQ ..... Avec des CHATS
* bruit de touches de piano *
Beethoven - Symphonie 8...
*musique sympathique*
Je suis actuellement aux Cafés des CHATS à Paris , un foyer qui réunit pleins de chats qui sont issus de la protection animale.
Et qui en fait ont été récupérés après avoir été abandonnés : par exemple trouvés dans la rue.
Et ici ils ont enfin trouvé un vrai foyer qui leur donne de l'amour et des croquettes.
...et de la coke...
Quelle était ta matière préférée à l'école ?
La cantine ...
Comment trouves-tu Emmanuel Macron ?
J'ai beaucoup aimé son dernier album.
♪ PARCE QUE C'EST NOTRE PROJEEEET ! ♪
LET'S GO ! ("C'est parti" en anglais)
Il est empaillé celui-là ouuuu ?
Ah non c'est un vrai.
Tu viens quand à la Réunion wesh ? J'ai l'impression qu'on en marge de la société.
Écoute .... Vous êtes pas du tout en marge. Nous, ici, en métropole, on vous kiffe tous !
Et je passe un très très gros big-up à tous les DOM-TOM.
Fais-toi juste la barbe de Wolverine.
Alors la barbe de Wolverine je pense qu'elle ne marche vraiment que sur Wolverine.
Sur moi cela risque de faire paysan *rire de paysan*
Quel est le pire surnom que l'on t'ai donné ?
Alors quand j'était au collège, vu que j'étais déjà très grand, maigre et avec une grosse touffe de cheveux sur la tête
On m'appelait coton-tige.
Mais bon maintenant ça a bien changé !
Maintenant je ressemble plus à un coton-tige mais avec du bide.
*Mange une croquette pour chats et avale*
Oh non...  Ils sont amoureux ♥
Alors penses-tu faire un court métrage un jour ?
Heu oui mais même si je n'aime pas trop le mot court métrage que je trouve un petit peu trop scolaire
Mais en tout cas je vais faire une petite vidéo de fiction bientôt sur ma chaîne qui ferra écho à ma vidéo sur les insomnies.
Que vous avez je crois plutôt aimé !
Il doit y avoir des salades qui sont jalouses de tes cheveux !
Euhh... Ecoute je sais pas mais en tout cas Il ne doit pas y avoir de salades qui sont jalouses de tes vannes !
Non ça c'est sûr *rire fier de soi*
Lui ca fait 6 mois qu'il est là
Il s'appelle "je sais pas descendre"
Fais-tu du stand-up dans des mariages, bar-mitzvah, et autres événements festifs sympathiques ?
heu non moi je fais que ça dans des...
foires à la saucisse !
Est-ce que tu acceptes de DABBER ?
Tu veux pas DABBER ? Pas de dab, pas de PÂTÉ !!!
As-tu des films, séries dans lesquels tu joues prochainement?
Alors j'ai écrit avec Cyprien et Julien Joslin ET Flobert
une série qui sortira bientôt sur TF1/YouTube
dans laquelle il y aura aussi Natoo et plein d'autres potes de YouTube
euh voilà une petite série dont on est assez fiers
et c'est pour TRÈS bientôt parce qu'on tourne là dans deux semaines
Il serait peut être temps de constuire une vie de famille non ?
T'as raison, je pense que je vais installer l'option Premium sur Tinder
Tu vas chez Lidl ?
Vous avez ça en M ?
Alors de quel chanteur étais-tu fan ado ?
Alors quand j'étais ado j'étais extrêment fan de la chanteuse du groupe Hanson
bah je me suis rendu compte, un jour,
que c'était totalement un homme
Voilà c'est une true story *rire gêné*
À quand le prochain clip musical ?
Alors c'est déjà en cours, je le tourne dans quelques jours
Euh par contre, je vais pas vous donner d'indices, ce serait un peu trop facile
♪ Ouverture de coffre dans Zelda ♪
Tu joues à des jeux PC ? Alors ouais, je joue pas mal à BattleField 1 sur PC
BF1 pour les intimes
et d'ailleurs j'ai comme projet de faire prochainement quelques Twitch avec des potes
je vous tiendrai au courant, mais pour l'instant j'ai pas encore réussi à brancher ma webcam
et le pire, c'est que c'est vrai
Alors qui est ton crush star ? J'crois que c'est elle
À quand un rasage de barbe ?
Frère, ça fait 30 ans que je l'attends cette barbe
Laisse moi kiffer au moins une semaine
Ooooh regardez comme il m'aime pour mes croquettes !
Alors, ils sont comment les abonnés suisses ? #RoyaumeDuWeb
Comme ça
*cris d'abonnés suisses*  Oh my fuck*ng god !
Ça c'est la puissance de Genève !
Wouuuh !
As-tu d'autres projets en dehors de YouTube ? Un deuxième spectacle par exemple.
Le premier était tellement drôle
Ah ben merci euuuuh Superman. Je vais bientôt commencer un second spectacle
mais ça prend beaucoup de temps à écrire, ça met au moins un an
et je compte m'y mettre, je pense cet été
Quelle est ta catégorie préférée sur YouPorn
J'aime bien la catégorie politique
Oooooh regardez comme il louche !
Pourquoi t'es plus avec HugoToutSeul?
Alors ma dernière vidéo avec Hugo date d'il y a à peu près.. une semaine
Donc faut suivre hein madame Lol... LolipopCut3
Personne veut ma souris morte ?
Tu as fait un bac ES ? Euh non j'ai fait un bac L
donc littéraire, et une licence d'arts
Y'a pas de blague, c'est juste une
petite info
Puisqu'on m'a demandé des fois de ne pas faire que des blagues
* bruit de bisou * on est en couple hein
Elle, elle est vaironne, c'est-à-dire qu'elle a les yeux pas de la même couleur
Personnellement j'adore
Plutôt Cyprien ou Squeezie ?
Connaîs pas, tu me mettras un lien et j'irai voir ce qu'ils font
* parle avec un accent chat * Bonjour !
Une madame Thavaux ? Alors Thavaud, avec un D peut-être,
avec un X, non.
Qu'est-ce que tu nous prépares comme vidéo pour les 10 millions d'abonnés ?
Alors j'ai déjà une petite idée en tête mais je suis ouvert
parce que j'ai envie de vous faire plaisir à vous, pas que à moi
donc si vous avez des petites envies ou des petites idées
n'hésitez pas à les suggérer en commentaires
et je vais réfléchir.
Quelle est ta passion hormis les vidéos ?
Les chiens.
Merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, mettez un pouce en l'air si vous avez un petit peu aimé le concept
Et on se quitte sur une citation, histoire de faire genre je lis des livres :
" La différence entre un chat et un chien
Le chien pense ils me nourrissent, ils me protègent : ils doivent être des dieux
Et le chat pense : ils me nourrissent, ils me protègent : je dois être Dieu" Ira Lewis
* bruit de livre qui tombe *
Mais toi aussi on t'aime bien
* bruit de bisou *
Grâce à la nouvelle mise à jour YouTube
quand vous cliquez ici sur ce bouton, depuis un téléphone ou un ordi
bah ça fait un truc nouveau, allez-y essayez, cliquez
avec votre doigt ou votre souris voiiilà
Pas mal non ? Plutôt cool, hyper simple pour s'abonner
beaucoup plus instinctif, donc merci Monsieur YouTube
et puis merci à vous je vous aime ÉNORMÉMENT
Lâchez un petit pouce en l'air svp.
Au revoir